(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos falar sobre a cláusula de inalienabilidade que aparece em
algumas matrículas.
O que é essa cláusula de inalienabilidade?
Ela serve para impedir que o bem seja alienado.
É usado normalmente quando ocorre uma doação ou testamento.
E qual seria a finalidade de alguém colocar essa cláusula numa doação ou no
testamento?
Exemplo, eu vou doar o meu imóvel para a minha avó, mas eu não quero que a
minha avó venda aquele imóvel, eu quero especificamente que ela fique naquele
imóvel, que ela use para morar ou que ela use para alugar.
Eu não quero que ela venda e fique com o dinheiro, eu quero que ela fique com
aquele imóvel especificamente.
Então eu faço essa doação e coloco essa cláusula.
Minha avó não conseguiria vender, por livre e espontânea vontade, aquele
imóvel.
Exatamente porque eu fiz uma doação e eu fiz essa doação de forma expressa para
constar essa cláusula de inalienabilidade.
Então a minha avó não conseguiria vender.
Essa cláusula então, ela impede somente alienação por livre e espontânea
vontade.
Mas ela não impede que o imóvel seja apenhorado para pagamento de dívida e que
depois ocorra o consequente leilão para quitar essas dívidas.
Por quê?
Vamos usar um exemplo.
Eu doei esse meu apartamento para a minha avó e coloquei essa cláusula.
Vamos supor que a minha avó nunca tenha pago o condomínio desse apartamento.
O condomínio então, ele tem o direito de receber o valor das cotas condominiais
que minha avó nunca pagou.
Seria uma injustiça tremenda que só pelo fato de eu ter colocado essa cláusula
na doação, que essa cláusula conste na matrícula do imóvel, que o condomínio
não pudesse cobrar essa dívida.
Seria como se o direito criasse uma figura para proteger o inadimplente.
Afinal, seria só existir uma simulação de uma doação, por exemplo, com essa
cláusula de inalienabilidade, para a pessoa ficar livre de ser cobrada por
qualquer dívida.
Porque vamos supor que a minha avó só tenha esse apartamento que eu doei para
ela.
Então, ela não pagaria e ela teria um aval de um instituto que o direito criou.
Isso, no final das contas, seria uma injustiça tremenda.
Então, a cláusula de inalienabilidade, ela só proíbe, obviamente, a venda por
livre e espontânea vontade.
Ela não proíbe a venda forçada.
E a gente já estudou que o leilão judicial, ele é uma venda, uma alienação
forçada.
Porque ele não decorre da vontade do proprietário.
O Poder Judiciário que vai mandar que aquele imóvel vá a leilão.
Consequência de existir essa cláusula de inalienabilidade na matrícula de um
imóvel que você está verificando um leilão.
A arrematação acontece normalmente e essa cláusula vai ser cancelada pelo juiz
que ordenou o leilão.
Então, nenhum problema em você participar de um leilão desse tipo.
Basta que você verifique se os outros procedimentos do leilão estão corretos e
essa cláusula não impossibilita, por si só, que o leilão aconteça.